okay so since we're on the dream topic
uh do you guys sleep talk yeah i should
talk
really don't think i started generally
just
this is going to sound terrible i just
screams
are you serious i like shouting probably
probably every time you die right
you've been around me right while i've
sleep talked right
um you don't i've never heard you sleep
talk i've heard you snore very heavily
yeah
like i don't know if you're screaming or
did was did you ever like sleep talk
during when you did your sabbath on you
slept on stream is there like i've muted
the mic
just in case i was fighting that dragon
that could only be defeated by racism
i only asked because aki has recently
started sleep talking like a lot yeah
and i'm like kind of concerned because
uh sh by sleep talk she randomly shouts
out phrases that just don't make sense
when you think about it in a sequential
manner like i remember just like because
ugg is the kind of person who like
literally head touches the pillow three
seconds later she's snoring i like
instantly like that which i'm so [ __ ]
jealous of but then now it's gotten to
the point where like
three seconds after the head hits the
pillow start snoring five seconds later
she says a random thing
and like i thought the first time she
did it i thought she was joking right
because it happened in the span of like
10 seconds so i just started laughing
like i think i remember her like like
she's like all right good night goes to
sleep starts snoring and then she just
goes
legs
[Laughter]
i was like maybe maybe she's like
she's even on a gun stream she's not
reading the title card
and then and then and then i started
laughing and i was like come on sweetie
what are you doing but she continues to
snore and i was like wait are you
serious and then she goes
butt fries
and so i had to shake her awake i was
like are you are you [ __ ] with me
right now
and she wakes up and she's like
what time is it i was like it's been 20
seconds what are you on
because in her head it's like an hour
has passed or something yeah yeah that's
weird again like whenever i sleep i
always know how much time has passed
yeah
yeah i don't understand how yeah like
sydney has a lot of nightmares um when
she sleeps and like i can i i know when
she's going through a nightmare because
she's she's just in panic mode like i i
can tell when she's running away from a
[ __ ] monster because she's just like
like
too much ntr
i don't know because like i know what
happens i have to wake her up and be
like you're in a nightmare honey don't
worry don't worry it's all so you're in
the safe zone i'm here i mean
is she like is she like when a dog has
like a dream of running and they're just
like stuck kicking legs
not only like when sydney's dreaming but
like the type of dream she's having yeah
because she won't say words but she'll
make noises depending on the type of
mood that she's in right so if she's
like having a nightmare which is like
most of the time she she'll like she'll
like start like [ __ ] panicking she'll
have like a panic attack in her dreams
and all this [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] when
she's like happy she'll just like laugh
and just smile and all this [ __ ]
like it's it's so obvious to say like
sometimes i i see her and she's just
like has like the biggest smile on her
face i'm just like
i wish i was you right now sydney
because you're having a [ __ ] fun
dream right now i don't know why i don't
know why
seeing someone with a huge [ __ ] grin
as they sleep is the creepiest thing
ever it's like could you just like
imagine walking into the room and
someone's just like
as they sleep like that that's really
creepy
i completely forgot i do actually i
don't scream sometimes i physically like
laugh myself awake but something
something really funny happens or
someone says a really funny joke and i
actually like physically laugh and i'm
just like oh i was i was dreaming i know
that you mentioned i think i've ever had
like funny dreams
i've never had a funny dream either have
i had funny dreams i don't know wow
that's so strange now that you've
mentioned that i'm depressed even in my
dreams it's always it's always something
[ __ ] extreme in my dreams yeah okay
it's never been like i've never had
funny dreams where i guess i'm in a deep
sleep but most of the time have you ever
had like a micro dream
yeah yeah where where you
where you it's it's when you're like
really really tired and you're not like
completely
it's so weird to describe because you
don't feel like you're completely asleep
but then you start hallucinating some
[ __ ] or like it's or like you you know
like a daydream like no not like a
daydream well what's what what does the
daydream county was you can't do for you
daydream is just like you're just bored
sitting there and you just start
imagining some [ __ ] no no so like so
like you're you're like actually really
like physically tired and you start
going to sleep right so you're not like
you're not like completely in a deep
sleep but you still start dreaming as
well so it's like half you like it's hot
i would say like half a lucid dream
because it's so easy it's like sometimes
i wake myself up by like falling over
and you get like a [ __ ] jerk it's
like a jerk and you're like yeah oh [ __ ]
the inception method the the inception
method and you're just like for [ __ ]
like i was so i was so close to being
asleep and then i had to like jerk
myself awake yeah and then sometimes
someone says something funny in there in
that
brief micro dream and i like laugh
myself awake i was like for [ __ ] sake
i was i was so close to sleeping i was
so close to actually being asleep
i want to be there when you experience
that just to see how [ __ ] weird it is
from my perspective it's just like god
just like sitting there
i've never seen god do this yeah it's
weird no but it's it's it's like because
i really i very rarely like micro dream
i don't know it's really weird but you
must have had the dream where you've
jerked yourself awake right have you
ever had that
you could have phrased that like you
could have phrased that like your body
literally jerks like because you you
like hallucinate that you're
is there another word i could use i feel
like that's the best
jolts okay jolt yourself jerk yourself
away yeah do you joke
oh thank god
baby oh thank god
george i've never used the word oh my
god oh i don't i don't i don't actually
i don't think i've ever used anything
synonyms for jokes
i've had uh i've had those like
stereotypical like on the train like
times where like you know you're just
closing your eyes because it's a long
train ride yeah you have that thing
where you fall forward
like that is that what you mean no i'm
talking about where you literally or
you're like literally in the dream
you're literally like you're literally
in half a dream and then you imagine
falling over or tripping over oh that
happens a lot yeah i do that my i like
kick my leg out or something yeah oh
yeah so that that's kind of what i'm
talking about but instead instead of
like imagining that i'm falling
sometimes i imagine someone saying
something funny or something funny
happening and then i just laugh
and then it's just like so it's like an
emotional joke yeah yeah it's like it's
like an emotional drive yeah it's
super weird i don't have that at all
like like yeah sometimes you know you
imagine like a ball flying towards you
and then you jerk yourself awake as well
yeah that's happened a lot that's
happened a lot in my dream as well yeah
like it's weak sometimes i won't be
dreaming of anything and then it will
very quickly cut to a ball yeah yeah i i
don't understand why i think faster yeah
i'm literally like not being a dream not
a dream not a dream and then something
just flies at me and i'm like
immediately fall asleep but it's not
like a full awake no that's what i mean
it's like it's like a micro dream right
where you're not fully asleep but you're
not fully awake and then you're your
brain's just like ah think fast
[ __ ]
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding you're
back
sleepwalking just a prank
anyone who sleepwalked you ever
sleepwalked yourself
my uncle apparently used to be a really
really bad sleepwalker and sleep talker